[Música]
cuando el presidente ruso vladimir putin
anunció la intervención militar de su
país en ucrania la calificó como una
operación especial en el donbass una
región al este de ucrania mayoría
rusoparlante y donde según el líder del
kremlin ejército ucraniano ha cometido
un genocidio este lunes moscú denunció
un ataque con misil en la ciudad de
unidas capital de una de las que el
kremlin considera ahora como repúblicas
populares independientes dicho ataque
dejó 20 muertos y 28 personas heridas
según el ejército ruso acusa a kiev de
ser el responsable de un crimen de
guerra al atacar a la población civil
kiev y sus aliados se han acusado a
rusia de planear operaciones de bandera
falsa para justificar una intervención
militar aún mayor en ucrania y por eso
quiero saludar entonces a nuestro primer
invitado el es luis fernando muñoz su
economista especialista en comercio
exterior vive en donges desde hace 36
años además su esposa es rusa louis
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en este espacio de france 24
directo américa cuéntenos cómo usted
llegó a ucrania en particular a esa zona
del este del país
buenos días muchas gracias yo llegué
aquí como pecado del icex que conocen en
colombia al instituto de crédito para
describirse en el exterior en 1985 a una
ciudad cercana a moscú ahí estudió ruso
y después al año siguiente las 36 años
llegué aquí a daniels a la universidad
politécnica estudian 1º ingeniera
eléctrica de años más tarde estudia
economía y me he dedicado al comercio
exterior pues casi toda la vida me casé
con una chica que estudiaba conmigo en
la ingeniería y que es profesora
actividad o universidad por eso me quedé
aquí y he vivido todos estos años desde
incluso el momento en que empezó esta
guerra civil
por por parte de que empezó el gobierno
la junta de clubes que se tomó el poder
después de un golpe está sin embargo
vivido aquí mis hijos ya no viven los
enviamos cosas interesantes están en la
universidad pero yo estoy aquí viviendo
con mi esposa danielle todos estos años
ahora louis háblenos de la situación
particular que se vivió el día de ayer
con este ataque de misil que se sabe
sobre esto y además le quiero preguntar
si pudo ver algo
si de hecho pues en estos días he
procurado no salir de casa
las veces aquí a un club de deporte al
lado si un club pues no más a estar en
forma pero no procuró no salir las
calles están vacías desde hace más de
tres semanas antes de que empezara esto
ya había habido una evacuación total en
los hombres han sido llamados todos como
reservas al ejército y las calles
estabilidad vacías de hecho yo estaba en
casa y puesto besarte porque la
explosión fue fuertísimo ya y créanme yo
vivo aquí en el centro de la ciudad y
esto fue a unos 300 metros en línea
recta desde mi casa el hecho de que no
se haya arrasado me dio media ciudad a
todo el centro porque esos misiles
pueden arrasar hasta 500 metros
alrededor desde el centro cierto fue
porque el sistema de antiaéreo logró de
alguna manera impedirlo pero cuando
estaba ya llegando a la tierra explotó
uno de los casettes esas bombas de
racimo tienen 50 casettes cada cada
amplia fracción tiene adentro varios
cientos 370 creo y
metrallas y pedazos puede invitar que
puedan ir fueron más de 20 y que habían
sido ya ya muerto 26 personas y de hecho
que es así que sufren un ciclo quiere
encender una ciudad donde no hay
absolutamente ningún objetivo militar ni
nada de eso eso es es triste pero
créanme que eso es uno master capítulo
de ocho años de guerra durante los ocho
años hemos vivido muchísimos ataques de
esta clase
afortunadamente desde el año 2017 no
habían habido ataques tan graves pero
antes de eso en el 14 en el 15 o william
muchísimos entonces pues
desgraciadamente ellos no han cambiado
su táctica y si antes dejábamos la culpa
sobre todo a los paramilitares neonazis
estás que son extremistas cierto
desgraciadamente este ataque fue hecho
por el ejército porque esos
paramilitares no tienen esta clase de
armamento que es
exclusivamente del ejército entonces si
fue el ejército el que lo hizo no son
conjeturas eso es ha demostrado
encontrar en sitios donde fue enviado
algo más de 80 kilómetros desde aquí
esos sistemas alcanzan 125 kilómetros de
alcance y por eso pues estamos dentro de
su rango de ataque el gen de estrés te
lo que ocurrió desgraciadamente murieron
incluso niños y pues fue un milagro que
hubieran detenido de alguna manera
destino había acabado con media ciudad
digamos en la audiencia entonces sé
quién la quien la dio el gobierno ruso
ya osea verificó que ese lanzamiento se
hizo de una base o de un puesto militar
de ucrania
desgraciadamente los superar el ejército
ucraniano no solamente los paramilitares
y el ejército usan una táctica enseñados
por los gringos lo más cierto
terroristas como el hippie y otros que
desgrana colocar todos sus armas en
sitios dentro de las ciudades marion por
estado sufriendo gravemente porque todos
estos nacionalistas y al igual que estos
que disparan ayer el ejército desde la
ciudad de para cross están dentro de la
ciudad o sea ellos han puesto todos sus
tanques y su equipos de visibles dentro
de la ciudad porque saben que los rusos
no van a acabar con la ciudad con
bombardeos como sí sino por ejemplo en
siria irak lo de la otan de ninguna
manera si produces consideran que es un
solo pueblo irb han dicho son son
hermanos son strauss son casi idénticos
no en los usos normales no piensan
acabar con todo el pueblo a pesar que
alguien piense una manera diferente si
luís pero pero también hemos visto
digamos el ejército rojito de las tropas
rusas dirigiéndose a varias ciudades
bombardeos destrucción en varias
ciudades ucranianas digamos como ven eso
ustedes desde ton jets donde se
encuentran o sea que dicen al respecto
de toda esta destrucción también
han tenido objetivos militares puede ser
al mejor un daño colateral pero en
hospitales
infantiles donde están mujeres
embarazadas como venes ustedes
bueno pues para que la gente tenga una
idea de lo que pensamos aquí tienen que
entender una cosa y que no es lo que
pensamos aquí que es la verdad de cada
diez noticias que emanan desde ucrania
11 son falsas créanme 11 son falsas e
incluido ese ataque a esa tan hospital
de niños estaba ya desocupado esos
nacionalistas habían sacado a toda la
gente habían hecho de ese hospital un
fortín estaban acantonados y desde ahí
estaban disparando incluso tenían armas
entonces créanme que si existen los
daños colaterales pero los rusos lo han
dicho desde un principio su objetivo son
la infraestructura militar de ucrania y
no el pueblo o la infraestructura civil
desgraciadamente y ya lo han comprobado
los documentos que han encontrado estos
días en todos los sitios de opciones de
donde ha salido el ejército planeando
corriendo hay documentos donde dice que
ellos pueden utilizar solamente los
edificios que son propiedad del estado
entre ellos escuelas universidades y
hospitales y esto lo que ellos hacen
si lo es pero bueno
indiscutiblemente también las imágenes
no mienten y pues si ha habido ataques a
edificios civiles incluyendo también
centros de salud igual gracias por por
estar con nosotros por saber su opinión
lo que piensan la gente sobre todo de
esta región del tumbas